I finally I thought I'd stay over
tonight why because we're girlfriend
boyfriend
to do what
I'm actually not sure expect the
unexpected it's not going to be whatever
you're thinking it's not it's not that I
think I would never
correct Barbie
sure I would never dream of it I would
say whatever Barbie says is exactly
right she's right it's not what you
think it is
unless it is
and then you know what it is and then it
but but I don't think that's what you
think it is I feel like
gonna be that but now I don't know what
everyone's thinking now they've had a
glimpse of
a few images and I think I'm not sure
what everyone's thinking I can't wait
for people
one word that's all I can say otherwise
Mattel will come in and box me up
foreign
[Applause]